لاعب البلاي ستيشن والاعظم في التاريخ كيف
تفنن مارادونا وكرويف واساطير الكره في
وصف ليونيل ميسي عبر التاريخ لم يحصد لاعب
واحد اشادات اساطير كره القدم باعتباره
الافضل في التاريخ اكثر من ليونيل ميسي
حيث تعددت الاوصاف التي نالها البرغوث
الارجنتيني من زملائه ومنافسه وسابقيه من
ايقونات اللعبه ميسي تجاوز مساحه شخصيات
كره القدم وحظي باعجاب الشخصيات العامه
والدبلوماسيه وبعض رؤساء الدول كتاكيد على
بصمته المختلفه عن جميع من دعبوا الكره
في 2010 قال مارادونا انه عرف اللاعب الذي
سيخلفه وهو ليونيل ميسي الذي يمتلك اشياء
مختلفه عن الجميع كما انه قائد ومثل اعلى
يحتذى به ذلك بينما كان ليو يبلغ من العمر
23 عاما فقط
قبل انطلاق كاس العالم 2014 حسم كرويف
الجدل بان ميسي هو افضل لاعب في تاريخ كره
القدم سواء فاز بالمونديال او لا وفي لقطه
شهيره في وثائقي عن ميسي ردد عباره شكرا
لله على ميسي ثلاث مرات بتاثر كبير
[موسيقى]
رغم صعوبه اعتراف السلطان بافضليه احد
والشخصيته التي تميل لمدح نفسه دوما الا
انه حين تحدث عن ميسي وصفه بالرجل الذي
يفعل الاشياء التي لا يعرف سرها سواه
وكانه لاعب بلاي ستيشن
[موسيقى]
المدرب الفرنسي شارك زلاتان الراي بوصفه
ميسي كلاعب بلاي ستيشن وزاد عليه من الشعر
بيتا بان لي يقادر على جعل المستحيل ممكنا
السير الذي انبهر بميسي حين وجاهه في 2009
اكد ان ليو جاء من كوكب اخر ذلك الكوكب
الذي جاء منه بيلي ومارادونا وعظماء كره
القدم عبر التاريخ
[موسيقى]
اسطوره تنس الاسبانيه المعروف بانتمائه
الى نادي ريال مدريد اكد على ان ميسي هو
الافضل في التاريخ هو افضل لاعب راى حيث
يمكنك الاستمتاع به حتى وان كان منافسك
الرئيس الامريكي السابق الذي لم يكن بين
اكثر المهتمين بكره القدم اكد رغبه ابنائه
في مقابله ليونيل ميسي والتعرف عليه الا
انه قال لسوء الحظ لم استطع ذلك
يعتبر باب هو اكثر البشر مدحا لميسي على
مدار السنوات تقريبا ولكن تصريح الابرز
ربما كان اعلانه عن الفخر بتدريب ليون وان
ذلك الامر هو الذي سيجعله فخورا حين يحكي
تلك القصه لاحفاده بعد سنوات طويله
[موسيقى]
النجم الانجليزي الذي كان صديقا
لكريستيانو رونالدو في مانشستر يونايتد
اكد ان ميسي ليس افضل من كريستيانو فقط
ولكنه الافضل في تاريخ كره القدم بشكل عام
هؤلاء واكثر تفننوا عبر السنوات في وصف
ميسي بعباراتهم كما تفنن هو في مداعبه
الكره لدرجه جعلت محاوله رصد كل ما قيل عن
لي ومستحيله وتحتاج الى ساعات من السرد
وربما لا تكفي ايضا اماما بهار العالم بما
قدمه النجم الارجنتيني
[موسيقى]